bon journée on a préparé une vidéo
depuis des semaines sur avengers est
vendu sa journée de tournage avec une
boîte de prod américaine tout simplement
une énorme caméras des costumes sur
mesure c'est une boîte de prod il faut
aussi les effets spéciaux ce genre de
choses ça va être une vidéo de malades
et super appliquée numéro d'amm
je suis là où je me trouve pas le moyen
âge et l'oeil du faucon doriot est
relative ou du privé auprès de 30
minutes finalement décoller car il peut
t'aider suis en tournage mais les
médecins ne pas monter dans l'avion rien
voilà
juste nous plante totalement impropres
au comédien ça me fait chier parce que
votre caste c'est dur est à faire
on parle d'un truc over style et on va
pas faire un truc de merde caméra c'est
juste des accessoires on fait des trucs
dégueulasses vie comment on y va non je
sens la blague arriver quoi ça est tenue
la chine a tout à tout et on décroche
américain on n'est plus dans le costume
français est pas exactement la même
taille de bouquié pourront s'intéresser
aujourd'hui est un cauchemar
grâce à ces quoi les gars ne fait pas
bon être tournage en face à fantasmes et
ses premiers effets spéciaux mois moi
j'ai un pote qui fait du dessin animé un
peu c'est pas des effets spéciaux du
dessin animé à la région
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va mettre en fait les écrans un petit
peu partout faire genre c'est un peu le
sujet de the avengers
vous pouvez y avait nos sorties les ipod
tisane une plaque de verre avec un petit
problème à nos grands pas cher il dit m
me lucie dieu décor c'est à dire à tout
le monde un seul temps d'un passage où
est offerte aux cayes se déplace sur
plus fort mais sur le sol
alors on avait un skateboard avec une
ficelle ou de la pluie de utilise une
mine paralysante qui ressemble
énormément finalement un bouchon dévier
ou pas du coude après un bon début j'ai
pas de doublure ok je suis un cascadeur
et je suis très content de fin de
tournage de cette vidéo
finalement la fecq les moyens du bord
c'était hyper drôle est franchement
joyeux romane ces temps de crise et à
bientôt sur internet